A NEW PR CAMPAIGN.
>> Reporter: TALK ABOUT
TURBULENCE, UNITED BETTER FASTEN
IT'S SEAT BELT, ATTACKED ON
TWITTER, BOARDED AS A DOCTOR,
LEFT AS A PATIENT, WE PUT THE
HOSPITAL IN HOSPITALITY, PA
PARODIED IN LATE NIGHT.
>> LOOK AT WHAT YOU DID?
>> GIVE US A PROBLEM, AND WE'LL
DRAG YOUR ASS OFF THE PLANE.
>> Reporter: THIS MOVIE CLIP
FROM AIRPLANE HAS TAKEN OFF.
THE WORD OF THE WEEK IS
REACCOMMODATE, AS WE CAN
REACCOMMODATE YOU THE EASY WAY
OR THE HARD WAY.
GETTING READY TO FLY INVOLVES
BUBBLE WRAP FOR MAN AND MAN'S
BEST FRIEND.
THE CAPTAIN HAS TURNED ON THE NO
PASSENGER SIGN.
MOST OF THE ONLINE SLINGS AND
ARROWS CAME VIA THE HASH TAG NEW
UNITED AIRLINES MOTTO.
WE HAVE FIRST CLASS, LOW CLASS
AND NO CLASS.
UNITED AIRLINES OFFERS NOW CABIN
CLASS, FIGHT CLUB.
AND PLEASE COVER YOUR HEAD AND
BRACE YOURSELF FOR A BEATING.
OLD COMMERCIALS ARE BEING TURNED
INTO MASHUPS.
>> PERFORMING TOGETHER WITH A
SINGLE UNITED PURPOSE.
>> OH, MY GOD!
LOOK AT WHAT YOU DID TO HIM!
>> THAT'S WHAT MAKES THE WORLD'S
LEADING AIRLINE FLYER FRIENDLY.
>> THEIR PARODY AS FROM OTHER
AIRLINES, SOUTHWEST, WE BEAT THE
COMPETITION, NOT YOU.
AND AN ACTUAL, REAL AD FROM
EMIRATES AIRLINES.
MOCKING UNITED WITH ITS OWN
SLOGAN, AND THIS, BECAME COMPLY
WITH ME.
>> AND WE'LL BEAT YOU SO BADLY,
YOU'LL BE USING YOUR OWN FACE AS
A FLOTATION DEVICE.
>> Reporter: UNITED IS NOW THE
ONE TAKING A BEATING AND I I